how did that make you feel that lamar
was on big brother and talking about you
i think it's so sweet that he says such
nice things about me and not to be
like arrogant but there
i wouldn't expect him not to say
anything nice
seems like there's no bad blood between
khloe kardashian and her ex-husband
lamar odom did such a beautiful thing
during her appearance on the not skinny
but not fat podcast chloe reacts to
lamarr talking about her during his time
on celebrity big brother earlier this
year i had some good dreams last night
you did
was i am i dreamt my ex-wife last name
i've just always been like we've been
cool with one another so there's i don't
expect anything negative but sometimes
people jump on that bandwagon just
for attention and i'm proud that he's
not doing that yeah lamar had nothing
but good things to say about chloe whom
he was married to from 2009 to 2013.
do you guys still talk
i miss her so much
i wish i could take that time back
how long were y'all married
four years
i miss you so much
then when he got evicted from the cbb
house lamar sent this message to his
ex-wife i miss you and i hope i get to
see you soon at the time the former nba
star opened up to e.t about why he
mentioned chloe so much they asked me a
lot about chloe on this show
and you know i just wasn't um you know
bringing up to bring her up i don't want
people to think you know
stalking her you know i can't get over
it anytime you know
a woman stands by you after you know
making such a huge mistake
and um
you know is there for you when i
couldn't walk or talk
or even you know
wipe my own backside
what she attempted to do or you know a
certain time i don't think you could
ever
you know forget about that person
especially you married this person after
30 days of knowing each other
the mistake he's referring to well
that's his drug overdose in 2015 which
put their pending divorce at the time on
hold after he was hospitalized after
chloe helped him recover and get sober
she reinstituted her divorce filing and
their marriage was terminated in 2016. i
just try to be as honest as transparent
about our relationship as possible maybe
it might help somebody else you know
who has who has a position of power
because of who they're married to
you know
what they've attained on their own
maybe might help them make the right
decision and on the podcast coco reveals
how she feels about lamar today i want
everyone to be successful and do what
they want to do like i'm happy for lamar
he looks like he's in a really good
place i mean the last time i've seen him
in person he was just recovering from
his overdose and so he wasn't
so
i don't know if the words advance but
like he wasn't so far along in his
recovery
and so to see him be so great like i i'm
happy for him and i'm rooting for him
and lamar he told e.t he has hopes for a
relationship with her in the future it
would be a blessing just to be
in her presence
um
you know but i understand what
you know that it happens and you know
people move on
in their lives and you know if i can be
her friend like i said that would just
be a blessing
for now coco is a single lady earlier
this year she split from her longtime
boo tristan thompson the former couple
shares a daughter four-year-old true
people do make mistakes and i don't you
know he's still a good person he's not a
good partner right and i you know i want
everyone to still have like a fair shot
at just being happy and having a good
life he's always going to be in my life
because of true and he's a great dad
and you know that's really all i need to
focus on is just his relationship with
true
[Music]